man that debate last night I got to tell
you the GOP lesser known debates didn't
really care for him didn't know if I
wanted to watch it but when we did it
was incredible the ramaswami stole the
show shattering all the online informal
polls but you know it the corporate
press is claiming he failed he did the
worst I love it the New York Times
saying Nikki Haley actually did the best
and V did the worst meanwhile all of the
trends all the searches are v v v he
absolutely nailed it so of course now
there's a clip going around of Ron
McDaniel who's very upset claiming that
if voted for Obama here's the best part
Tim Cass got a scoop right after the
show because of course like we know
everybody who's basically at the debate
and uh ra apparently said as VI was
roasting her he's an a-hole he's an
a-hole he's not getting a scent from us
V commented saying this is corrupt
basically calling it corruption so this
is crazy